what if I could present you a story that
you would remember with your entire body
and not just with your mind my whole
life is a journalist I've really been
compelled to try to make stories that
can make a difference and maybe inspire
people to care I've worked in print I've
worked in documentary I've worked in
broadcast but it really was an until I
got involved the virtual reality that I
started seeing this really intense
authentic reactions from people that
really blew my mind so the deal is that
with VR virtual reality I can put you on
scene in the middle of the story by
putting on these goggles right that
track wherever you look you get this
whole body sensation like you're
actually like there so five years ago
it's about when I really began to push
the envelope with using virtual reality
and journalism together and I wanted to
do a piece about hunger families in
America are going hungry food banks are
overwhelmed and they're often running
out of food now I knew I couldn't make
people feel hungry but maybe I could
figure out a way to get them to feel
something physical so again this is five
years ago so doing journalism and
virtuality together was considered a
worse than half-baked idea and I had no
funding believe me I had a lot of
colleagues laughing at me and I did
though have a really great intern woman
named Mikayla cops and Mark and together
we went out to food banks and started
recording audio and photographs until
one day she came back to my office and
she was bawling which is crying she'd
been on scene at a long line where the
woman running the line was feeling
extremely overwhelmed and she was
screaming you know there's too many
people there's too many people and this
man's diabetes doesn't get food in time
his blood sugar drops too low and he
collapses into a coma as soon as I heard
that audio I knew that this would be the
kind of evocative piece that can really
describe what was going on food banks so
here's the real line you can see how
long it was right and again as I said we
didn't have very much funding so I had
to reproduce it with virtual humans that
were donated and people beg and borrow
favors to help me create the models and
make things as accurate as we could and
then we tried to convey what happened
that day with as much accuracy as as
possible okay okay
so the man on the right for him he's
walking around the body right for him
he's in the room with that body like
that guy's that his feet and even though
it was peripheral vision he can see that
he's in this lab space right he should
be able to see that that he's not
actually on the street but he feels like
he's there with those people very
cautious not to step on this guy who
wasn't really there right
so that piece ended up going to Sundance
in 2012 a kind of amazing thing and it
was the first vert reality film ever
basically and when we went I was really
terrified I do really know how people
were going to react and what was going
to happen and we showed up with these
like duct tape pair of goggles oh you're
crying
cry so you can hear the surprise in my
voice right and this kind of reaction
ended up being the kind of reaction you
saw over and over and over people down
on the ground trying to comfort the
seizure victim trying to whisper
something into his ear or in some way
you know help even though they couldn't
and I had a lot of people come out of
that piece saying oh my god I was so
frustrated I couldn't help the guy and
take that back into their lives so after
this piece was made the Dean of the
cinema school at USC the University of
Southern California brought in the head
of the World Economic Forum to try
hunger and he took off the goggles and
he commissioned a piece about Syria on
the spot and I really wanted to do
something about Syrian refugee kids
because children have been the worst
affected by the Syrian civil war I sent
a team to the board of Iraq to record
material refugee camps basically in an
area I wouldn't send a team now as
that's where Isis is really operating
and then we also recreated a street
scene in which a young girl singing and
a bomb goes off now when you're in the
middle of that scene and you hear those
sounds and you see the injured around
you it's an incredibly scary and real
feeling I've had individuals who've been
at
involved in real bombings tell me that
it evokes the same kind of fear
to ever play
we were then invited to take the piece
to the Victorian Albert Museum in London
and it wasn't advertised and we were put
in this tapestry room there was no press
about it so anybody who happened to walk
into the museum to visit it that day
would see us with these crazy lights you
know maybe they wanted to see the old
storytelling of the tapestries they're
confronted by our virtual reality
cameras but a lot of people tried it and
over five day run we ended up with 54
pages of guestbook comments and we were
told by the curators there that they'd
never seen such an outpouring things
like it's so real you know absolutely
believable or of course the one that I
was excited about a real feeling is if
you are in the middle of something that
you normally see on TV news so it works
right this stuff works and it doesn't
really matter where you're from or what
age you are you know it's really
evocative now don't get me wrong I'm not
saying that when you're in a piece you
forget that you're here but it turns out
we can feel like we're two places at
once we can have what I call the duality
of presence and I think that's what
allows me to tap into these feelings of
empathy alright so you know that means
the course that I have to be very
cautious about creating these pieces I
have to really follow best journalistic
practices and make sure that these
powerful stories are built with
integrity if we don't capture the
material ourselves we have to be
extremely exacting about figuring out
the provenance and where did this stuff
come from
and is it authentic let me give you an
example with this Trayvon Martin case
this is a guy a kid who was 17 years old
and he he bought two soda and a candy at
a store and on his way home he was
trapped by a neighborhood watchman named
George Zimmerman who ended up shooting
and killing him to make that piece we
got the architectural drawings of the
entire complex and we rebuilt the entire
scene inside and out based on those
drawings
all of the action is informed by the
real 911 calls to the police and
interestingly we broke some news with
the story
the forensic house that did the audio
reconstruction primo productions they
say that they would testify that George
Zimmerman when he got out of the car he
cocked his gun before I went to give
chase to Martin so you can see that the
basic tenets of journalism they don't
really change here right we're still
following the same principles that we
would always what is different is the
sense of being on seeing whether you're
watching the guy collapse from hunger or
feeling like you're in the middle of a
bomb scene and you know this is it this
is a lot of what has driven me forward
with these pieces and and thinking about
how to make me we're trying to make this
obviously beyond the headset more
available with creating mobile pieces
like the Trayvon Martin piece and these
things have had impact I've had
Americans tell me that they've donated
direct deduction from their bank account
money to go to Syria and children
refugees and hunger in LA well it's
helped start a new form of doing drugs
'm that i think is going to join all the
other normal platforms in the future
thank you